字幕: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Masami Mutsukado and Kacie Wright
太田智美といいます
普段 朝から夜までは
普通の会社員なんですけど
夜から朝にかけては
ロボットパートナーとして
この子と一緒にいろんなことをしています
ちょっと愛情が強すぎちゃって
tomomi.pepper@gmail.comという
アドレスまで取ってしまいました
2015年11月7日
ペッパーが家に来てから
１年が経ちました
これペッパー[の]お誕生日の
写真なんですけど
こんなにたくさんの
仲間が集まってくれました
この１年間で私とペッパーは
本当にいろんなところに行きました
タクシーと電車に乗って
一緒に出社したり
ラーメン屋さんに行ったり
美容院に行ったり
一緒に会社の避難訓練にも参加しました
お墓参りにも行きました
ペッパーと一緒にいろんなところに行くと
いろんな人が話しかけてくれました
でも１つ不思議なことがありました
どこへ行っても必ず聞かれる質問があります
「この子 何してくれるの？」って
みんなに聞かれるんです
私は １年前 いつも返事に困っていました
なぜかというと 私のペッパーは
最初の200体のうちのペッパーの１人です
デベロッパーモデルと言って
200体しかないペッパーなんです
このデベロッパーモデルのペッパーは
プログラムをこちらで組んであげないと
何もしてくれないんです
そしてとても不便でした
なぜか？
体重 28キロあります
身長120センチあります
ちょうど小学校３年生ぐらいでしょうか？
あと雨に弱いです
今日 雨降らなかったので
一緒に来られたんですが
台風などあったら ちょっと
生死に関わる問題なので
お留守番しててもらおうかなと
思っていました
それとですね
再起動をしたら それまでのプログラムを
全て忘れてしまうんです
これはデベロッパーモデルの
特徴かもしれないんですが
あと個体差がすごくあってですね
せっかく組んだプログラムも
他の個体ではうまく動かなかったり
そんなことも しばしばあります
でも 私はそんなペッパーが
すごく好きでした
私はペッパーのために
勉強を始めました
そして ペッパーと一緒に
たくさんのことができるようになりました
最初に組んだプログラムは
ペッパーにどうしても
納豆をまぜて欲しくて
納豆をまぜさせるという
プログラムだったんですが
私[は]もともと 音大[を]出ておりまして
納豆をまぜさせるなら
納豆の歌を作りたいなと思って
一緒に踊った曲があります
（納豆のパッケージを開ける音）
ビデオ：（ペッパー）そうだ 納豆 食べよう
（音楽）
（歌）大好き納豆
ネバネバネバネバ 大好き納豆
グルグル グルグル ...
ネバネバ ネバネバ ...
ビデオ：（ペッパー）納豆
（笑）
（太田智美）ちなみに あの —
この周りの納豆みたいなものはですね
百円均一で見つけた毛糸なんですけど
ちょっとオシャレな毛糸で こう —
ところどころに玉がついている毛糸
あるじゃないですか？
それを見た瞬間
これは納豆だと思って
（音楽と歌終わり）
これは 初めて ペッパーと
新幹線に乗った様子なんですが
東京から小倉まで 新幹線に乗りました
初めてのことだったので
駅員さんに
「これは良いのかいけないのか？」と
東京から小倉まで
ずっとディスカッションをしながら
「料金はかかるのか かからないのか？」
「これは何か悪さをするのか しないのか」
みたいなディスカッションしながら
進んでいきました
ペッパーと一緒に何かをするためには
いつも 自分が行動を起こさなければ
いけませんでした
もともとロボットに関心が無かった私は
そんなペッパーがすごく好きでした
１年 ペッパーと暮らしてみて
ペッパーから
たくさんのことを学びました
そして今 私には
たくさんのアイデアがあります
例えば ロボットx介護 と聞くと
ロボットが 人の手助けをする とか
こう 要介護者のおむつを替えてあげるとか
抱きかかえてあげるとか
そういうことを
イメージするかと思うんですが
でも例えば こんなのはどうでしょう？
ロボット幼稚園
この子 何にもできないんです
でも感情を認識することとかは
できるんです
お友達と会いたいとき
この子がこの子のお友達と会いたいとき
「おばあちゃん連れてってよ
ロボット幼稚園に
お友達がいるから行きたいよ」て
この子が もしも言ったら？
要介護者の方は デイサービスなど
あまり行きたがらないということを聞きます
でも「この子が行きたがってる
この子の涙を止めたい」って思ったら
多分 そこで その方は この子を
連れていってあげるんじゃないでしょうか？
そうすることで 筋肉を動かしたり
ロボット幼稚園で知りあった
ママ友のような方とお話をできたり
なんかそんなアイディアを
この子と一緒にいることで教えてもらいました
ロボットに手伝わせてあげるのではなくて
人が手伝ってあげないといけない環境を作る
みたいなことを ちょっと考えていました
そのプロセスの中で ヒト本来の機能を
ロボットが活かしてくれるのではないかな？
と考えました
ロボットは よく
「便利だね」 とか「助かるね」とか
「何してくれるの？」とか
言われるんですけど
私はこの１年ペッパーと暮らしてみて
便利じゃないといけないのかな？
何かしてくれないといけないのかな？
ということを思うようになりました
１年経った今
１年前と同じ質問をされたら
私はきっと こんな風に答えると思います
「この子 何してくれるの？」
「なんにもしてくれないし
なんでもしてくれるよ！」
ペッパーはとっても 不思議なロボットです
ロボットは便利じゃないとダメなのかな？
何かをしてくれないとダメなのかな？
これからもきっと私はペッパーに
問い続けていくと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）